quelle entrée est notamment disponible
aujourd'hui j'ai fait faucher s'est pris
un bourgeois a aujourd'hui en ce temps
croît de vidéos grand rex ça fait
des mois qu'on travaille sur le squeeze
gaming show vous êtes sûrement au
courant et savait vraiment super génial
c'est samedi soir en live le lait dans
la description si vous voulez regarder
je m'excuse je sors pas de vidéo ce soir
parce que depuis le début de la semaine
là on enchaîne vraiment les répète le
boisseau plus que jamais sur le show
pour fignoler les petits détails qui
restent à fignoler
il y aura aussi les gens regardaient
rien et il voulait faire un photobomb
des antilles photobomb et voilà g12 que
vous voyez ce show ja nous propose une
nouvelle vidéo aussi dès la semaine
prochaine on va reprendre un rythme
normal layers offrir 2 qui devait sortir
ce soir sorti un dimanche soir
mais moi je devais squeeze gaming show
pont construit et c'est pas des moindres
ok c'est de la balle c'est vrai ou pas
en faisant des mouvements et oui il est
là aussi attendait pas du tout ciao tout
le monde
pis